the secret's out we know what our pets
do all day this secret life of pets two
returns this summer on June 7th here's
everything you need to know before you
go and the first secret life of pets we
fell in love with some sweet furry
personalities on the move in New York
City max our main pup and excitable
terrier Gidget a loving and very fluffy
Pomeranian Duke a larger-than-life mixed
breed dog snowball the fiercest bunny
there ever was look at me and your
leader buddy a dachshund who loves to
chillax Mel
a hyperactive yet don't beep ugh here
you go and see you later Chloe a sassy
tabby the original film brings our
daydreams to life by portraying the
animals on wild adventures with colorful
characters the story begins with max he
happily had Katie and their home all to
himself until she brought home a second
dog this is Dooku Bjork
Duke and Max's relationship doesn't
start off on the right paw what are you
doing see what I did there max
immediately tries to frame Duke by
dirtying the apartment while Katie is
out the adventure begins after Duke and
Max cut loose from their dog walker and
are picked up by animal control two four
six eight you know it 10 okay
did you notice his melon buddy on their
way back from the dog park without Max
and do lost scared so so handsome we've
got to find him and bring him home let's
go snowball lizard and tattoo beat up
the animal control officers and drive
off with the truck to save a dog named
Ripper
welcome to the old blood specs these
guys are older killers the alley cats
appear and revealed to the flesh pets
that Max and Duke didn't kill their
owners the rest of the pets go to pops a
dog whose owner is rarely home so his
house is a popular hangout spot in the
neighborhood pups guides the pets to the
sewers and there they run into the flush
pets they all discover they're looking
for max and Duke
I think we're gonna get them dogs oh man
a very hungry Maxim Duke make it to
Brooklyn safely
let's eat they feast of the sausage
factory and bunny Duke tells max about
his former owner Fred Duke we got to go
to your house they find Dukes house
there's a cat there that tells them that
fred has died and a new family lives in
his home doof becomes very sad about
Fred and lashes out at max for bringing
them home let's go come on this isn't
your home anymore why did you bring me
here max wait a minute this is my fault
you know I was trying to help you you
were trying to get rid of me
Animal Control shows up immediately and
picks up dude
as Max is trying to get Duke the flesh
pets appear from out of the sewers
[Music]
as the plush pets around the bridge they
see max pulling snowball who looks on
alive from the bus but in perfect timing
Gidget saves max from the rage of the
flesh pets the bus falls into the river
and max jumps in to save do snowball
also jumps into the water to grab the
keys and passes them to max they all
escape safely tattoo steals attacked you
to get the pets home max tells Gidget
how he felt seeing her save the day and
she shares her excitement with him
the budge pets are about to return to
the sewer when Molly a little girl see
snowball and adopt him making him happy
after a long a crazy day all the owners
returned home they clearly have no idea
what their furry friends got into Kitty
is just so happy to see that max and
Duke are sitting together when she
returns so how'd it go great right an
secret life of pets - were reunited with
our lovable fluffy friends and are
introduced to new four-legged ones it's
a dog out of City film the movie follows
my character I'm the story of it I play
the character of Max and Max is a very
high-strung neurotic
dog that you know what he cares too much
the baby does leave it in this know he's
staying home with me where it's safe and
he sort of gets his whole world turned
upside down when his summer is spent at
a farm but you have this ensemble cast
Tiffany Haddish okay you don't listen
Eric Stonestreet not only can we not say
PA okay we can't also can't say ba ll
especially Kevin Hart I can't wait for
you to see my move and Lake Bell
cattitude is a state of deep every
little Side Story they go down could be
its own film
plus you have the Harrison Ford for
Godsey no I'm not the star of the movie
Harrison Ford's in it
you want to join me I'm not gonna say
I'm the star of a movie that has
Harrison Ford in it No
so now you know and now you can go see
The Secret Life of pets to sit high-five
good boy
[Music]
[Music]